et à j moins 83 c'est notre rendez vous
désormais de madère avec l'élection
présidentielle ici en france france 2022
l'heure du choix chaque lundi à 20h15
heure de paris à partir du 14 mars nous
vous retrouverons chaque jour à cet
horaire h rennes verdure bonjour bonsoir
raphaël bonsoir à vous tous on sort d'un
week end très chargé pour tous les
candidats mais c'est eric zemmour qui a
fait le plus réagir après ses propos sur
les enfants en situation de handicap il
devrait selon lui être prises en charge
dans des établissements spécialisés
plutôt qu intégré au sein de l'école de
la république il a même dénoncé je cite
une obsession de l'inclusion en france
c'était vendredi dernier depuis
l'ensemble de la classe politique a fait
part de son indignation eric zemmour a
tenté de s'expliquer dans une vidéo
youtube sans pour autant renier ses
propos ni présenter des excuses on verra
dans les prochains jours a failli si
cette sortie aura des conséquences sur
sa campagne il ya eu aussi cette semaine
de nouvelles candidatures des animaux
caresser du fromage déguster et même une
première mondiale un meeting en quasi
réalité virtuelle le récap politique est
signée florent rodo et aurélien porcher
c'est l'histoire d'une campagne qu'il
aimerait voir décoller
meeting d'un nouveau genre pour jean luc
mélenchon avec l' envie de décrocher la
lune
quand on est dans l'espace ne croyez pas
une seule seconde qu'on fasse autre
chose que de s'occuper de la terre
l'insoumis et dans l'espace christiane
taubira dans le brouillard mais
l'ancienne garde des sceaux a pris sa
décision je suis candidate à la
présidence de la
hat gauche le combat est lancé
vainqueur par ko pour l'instant la
désunion car chacun veut boxer seul de
son côté
[Musique]
c'est tout seul on fait rien on a
intérêt
dans le programme de la socialiste un
impôt sur la fortune climatique copier
coller de yannick jadot
l'écologiste en mission éveil des
consciences au pied des alpes enneigées
pratique tout ce ski le déni c'est sur
ce qu'ils pensent que dans les années
qui viennent il y aura de la neige tous
les hivers
ouf de la neige il y en a encore dans le
doubs où valérie pécresse veut casser
son image de parisienne en allant comme
disait jacques chirac tâter le cul des
vaches elles n'ont pas trop l'habitude
on la retrouve en grèce dans le nouveau
camp de samos où les migrants sont
surveillés de très près si on ne se met
pas créé justement une alliance des pays
frontaliers pour que le modèle grec
devienne le modèle européen alors eh
bien on continuera à voir une europe
passoire qui est celle aujourd'hui du
président matheron elle aussi a en ligne
de mire le second tour de la
présidentielle
ar qui le courant ne passe pas entre les
éoliennes et marine le pen
ce projet de parc éolien en mer est
vraiment la démonstration
que nos dirigeants ont perdu la tête
voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine
vivement la prochaine
et la question que tout le monde se pose
encore à l'issue de sept semaines de
campagne ses y aura-t-il un seul pilote
dans l'avion de la gauche en tout cas
ils sont huit désormais dans la course
la maire socialiste de paris anne
hidalgo jean luc mélenchon la france
insoumise fabien roussel du parti
communiste l'écologiste yannick jadot
philippe poutou du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste pardon nathalie arthaud
de lutte ouvrière l'ancien ministre de
l'économie arnaud montebourg et enfin
l'ancien ministre la justice christiane
taubira on en parle avec roselyne febvre
chef du service politique de france 24
bonsoir roselyne traditionnellement la
gauche roselyne c'est le partage des
richesses et le sens du collectif mais
ce dernier mot semble régner en tout cas
pour le moment du vocabulaire des
candidats à gauche absolument et
j'imagine que vous avez tous les deux
raphaël aussi lu les trois mousquetaires
et le fameux slogan de l'époque c'était
un pour tous et tous pour un aujourd'hui
la gauche pourrait transformer un pour
tous chacun pour soi la gauche ressemble
aussi aux atrides vous savez c'est cette
famille de la mythologie grecque qui
était maudite par les dieux à force de
s'écharper de se tuer de se trahir mais
ce qui paraît aujourd'hui un mythe et
bien c'est cette union de la gauche on a
l'impression qu'on vous raconte une
histoire au temps de françois mitterrand
il était une fois la gauche il y a très
longtemps dans un pays lointain alors
oui sous françois mitterrand l'union de
la gauche sous lionel jospin aussi la
gauche plurielle mais tout ça paraît
très loin alors certains se lancent à
parler de recomposition moi j'ai plutôt
envie de parler de décomposition et si
si mélenchon on avait parlé dans son
meeting of fatick je ne sais pas quelle
odeur il aurait envoyé en tout cas
yannick jadot lui vous rassembler
rappelez vous il ya quelques mois et
tout le monde lui avait ri au nez et lui
avaient claqué la porte au nez donc lui
du coup il a fait sa petite primaire
tranquillou et puis maintenant on vient
le tarabuste et avec cette histoire de
primaires mais on peut se demander où
était christiane taubira à ce moment là
elle était chez elle en guyane elle
n'avait pas l'air d'être taraudé par une
envie présidentielle à l'on peut se
demander quelle mouche l'a piqué dieu
seul le sait peut-être par orgueil
diront certains l'orgueil de se croire
comme si on continue à filer la
métaphore
est bien mythologique une sorte de deus
ex machina vous savez dans les tragédies
grecques le deus ex machina était le
dieu qui sort de la boîte et qui vient
arrangé les affaires des hommes eh bien
elle pense peut-être qu'elle va sortir
de la boîte quel sens à sa candidature
est ce que c'est un coup de poker un
coup de jarnac si elle est adoubé par la
primaire évidemment elle ira elle ira et
on lui reprochera peut-être comme en
2002 d'avoir fait perdu perdre la gauche
mais est ce qu'elle peut faire perdre la
gauche la réponse est non puisque la
gauche a déjà perdu pourquoi parce que
si on fait le total gauche et bien il y
en a à 2 3 à 4%
le parti communiste a deux montebourg a
enfin bon bref c'est la gauche
éparpillée façon puzzle et vous
connaissez le titre du film avec james
dean la fureur de vivre on pourrait
rebaptiser la fureur de perdre ma fleur
de peau en tout cas dans cette
cacophonie 1 pour l'heure à gauche qu'il
venait d'écrire aux l'insee pour l'heure
le candidat désormais olfactif donc un
jean luc mélenchon qui semble plus en
odeur de sainteté à gauche a pas mal
tout à fait et d'ailleurs avec ckoi il
est entre 7 et 10% mais c'est broadway
c'est il peut il peut en tout cas se
dire que il fait une performance à à
gauche mais il fait une faute il a fait
une performance ce week-end franchement
et on peut le reconnaître on voit les
images derrière vous de ce meeting alors
vous le disiez hoffalt hic c'est à dire
que lorsqu'il parlait de la mer parce
que la france la france 1
un parc maritime énorme donc on avait
des airs diodes il parlait de l'espace
donc on était à 360° dans l'espace
d'autant que l'espace c'est son nouveau
dada
il pense que il faut remettre en
question la dissuasion nucléaire pour
parce que il a un peu la tête déjà dans
les étoiles il imagine la guerre des
étoiles il son discours c'est de dire
finalement les russes on a vu que les
russes pouvaient envoyer des
bombardes et satellite de la terre donc
ils pensent que la prochaine guerre sera
dans l'espace en tout cas ça marche ils
racontent des histoires aux français ils
innovent et c'est ce qui plaît on dit
toujours que dans une présidentielle il
faut raconter un récit est bon en tout
cas il a trouvé il a trouvé son récit et
ça plaît voilà merci beaucoup roselyne
pour cet édito je le rappelle on vous
retrouve demain dans une version longue
de votre émission mardi politiques
représentés avec frédéric rivière de rfi
des candidats rosine viens de le dire
qui se disputent pour l'heure à gauche à
8,1 à peine un quart des suffrages des
français si l'on en croit les sondages
c'est dire le glissement à droite de
l'électorat oui effectivement raphaël
même si selon les sondages les
problématiques du pouvoir d'achat ou de
la santé figurent en tête des facteurs
qui influenceront le plus le vote des
français devant l'immigration et
l'identité nationale dans les discours
et les interventions médiatiques ces
thèmes reviennent sans cesse alors
comment cette droitisation et elle vu de
l'étranger notamment sur le continent
africain voyez le reportage à dakar de
sarah sakho
[Musique]
la campagne présidentielle française est
bien suivi ici aussi au sénégal
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux et
pour en parler je me trouve avec deux
citoyens sénégalais engagés mamba soirée
entrepreneur social et abdou cissé
blogueur militant des droits de l'homme
bonjour messieurs
alors qu'avez vous retenu de ce début de
campagne parce que c'est vraiment cette
montée de l'extrême droite avec
certaines une certaine vision qui est
aujourd'hui incompréhensible dans un
monde où nous vivons quand destin en
commun la politique internationale et
handball m'intéresse beaucoup pour
prendre un exemple combien l'élimination
lorsqu'il parle de créolisation je pense
que c'est assez intéressant parce que ça
dans ce moment comment vivons justement
l'identité et la question migratoire qui
sont des thèmes vraiment me présent dans
ce début de campagne comment vous le dit
puis le sénégal sur la question
migratoire pour y apporter une réponse
je pense qu'il faut s'attaquer aux
causes racines de ce problème et c'est
là où je pense que les candidats loupé
le coche justement et essaye vraiment de
polémiquer sur des choses qui
véritablement ne vont pas sans gêner les
conséquences de l'immigration rapport à
la question de l'emploi ya beaucoup de
fantasmes ou à une organisation dont du
ciment nous prévoyons de fournir les
informations circonstanciées vérifier
sur la substitution parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de filles ou de fausses
informations emmanuel macron avait
promis en 2010 est de changer le rapport
de la france au continent africain quel
bilan tirez-vous de son action à ce
sujet là je dirais que le bilan est un
peu mitigé un bon il ya eu des discours
il ya eu des mots mais il n'y a pas eu
de changements par rapport
à la relation à l'arrivée
enfin le rapport de la france et
l'afrique et ses 500 ans d'histoire qui
ne peut pas être résolu en cinq ans je
pense qu'aussi c'est aux citoyens
africains européens et notamment
français de prendre conscience que c'est
un saint jouin systémique les sénégalais
vont sans doute continuer à suivre la
politique française en attendant ils
sont concernés par une autre campagne
électorale celle des élections locales
sénégalaises qui se tiendront ce
dimanche
et le monde arabe est également très
attentif à ce qui se passe en france la
présidentielle là aussi intéresse
beaucoup pour des raisons diverses on en
parle ce soir avec vous taoufik comme
juillet d' présentateur je le rappelle
sur la chaîne arabophone de france 24
bonsoir pourquoi est-ce que la
présidentielle en france fascine autant
le monde arabe pour plusieurs raisons
raisons géographiques proximité
géographique surtout avec la
méditerranée cette mer quelque chose de
civilisation comme des vers la bretelle
puis des raisons historiques je vais pas
d énumérer présence française pendant
l'époque coloniale au maghreb présence
française sous mandat britannique en
syrie et au liban puis une chose à 20
vraiment à mentionner c'est que la
france et les membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité donc ça intéresse
tout le monde la france joue un rôle
moteur aussi au sein de l'union
européenne donc ça intéresse aussi tout
le monde et à une présence française et
puis la france est une force mondiale ce
qui est normal que les pays arabes
s'intéressent à ce prix on comprend que
ce qui se passe en france est un enjeu
au sein du monde à mais il ya un intérêt
pour cette présidentielle en particulier
toufik parce que maintenant nous avons
deux extrêmes nous avons l'extrême
droite et on à l'extrême de l'extrême
droite vous connaissez très bien le
nombre de la communauté arabe qui se
trouvent en france donc il ya un danger
pour beaucoup on suit qu'est ce que ça
va donner pourquoi ce discours sur
l'immigration pourquoi ce discours sur
la sécurité pourquoi ce discours sur
l'islam surtout quand on sait que eric
zemmour il est d'origine algérienne donc
ça intéresse encore plus pire c'est un
phénomène que les gens essayent de
comprendre et et puis le problème aussi
des visas parce que beaucoup
monde arabe s'intéresse aussi à ce sujet
vous souvenez le camp chirac était à
alger le premier slogan qui a été qu'on
a entendu c'était des visages merci
beaucoup taoufik et je précise qu'on
peut vous retrouver tous les vendredis à
19h10 heure de paris dans une semaine en
france donc votre émission consacrée à
la présidentielle sur la chaîne
arabophone de france 24 et la france
évidemment continuer à en parler puisque
c'est notre rubrique à présent allons
enfants de la patrie h rennes oui
raphaël jusqu'à la présidentielle on va
se rendre dans diverses régions pour
prendre le pouls du pays à travers des
portraits de français ont par cette
semaine dans le béret à la rencontre
d'un barman ambulants sébastien cherrier
qui essayent de redonner vie au petit
village où les commerces ferment les uns
après les autres c'est un portrait
réalisé par julie d'une golf et florence
vinit
[Musique]
moi je suis un enfant devait du berry
j'ai toujours vécu ici
j'ai tellement connu la vie dans des
petits villages
les bistrots les petites épiceries des
boulangers enfin je veux dire la vraie
vie et moi de voir tout ça ferme et
ça bouffe et c'est de là que tu lis des
deux
pouvoir faire un bistrot mais ambulant
mal en juin on vient d'arriver à saint
léger en fait si je viens tous les
quinze jours
[Musique]
aurélie garneau maire de saint léger le
petit ce qui nous manque voilà ce serait
un bar ouvert tout le temps sur notre
commune le dernier a fermé il ya six ans
et une petite épicerie avec un dépôt de
pain c'est vrai que même à la
boulangerie les gens il se rend compte
depuis les années 2000 je pense qu'il ya
eu un gros problème déjà l'euro en euros
a fait du mal à flinguer tout énormément
de commerce et puis là il ya eu des
carrefours du grand commerce comme ça
qu'on commence à se monter balla de la
20 tout vaut moins cher
jma 10,3 quirin berrichon n' y applique
9 5 ans je me rends compte que le barman
toxicologue du village aussi des gens
même besoin de parler
c'est soit on les anciens qui met
vraiment une ambiance que des jeunes
moi ce qui me touche le plus c'est quand
c'est une personne âgée qui vient boire
six gamins ce que tu as fait c'est
vraiment bien
l'idée était simple mais il fallait y
penser
citoyens
[Musique]
ma priorité si je serai président moi ça
serait drôle un avis à tous les petits
villages rouvrir un des petits commerces
les bouchers des boulangeries des
pharmacies les écoles mois là la grande
priorité les petits villages et deuxième
point je pense ne plus taxer tout ce qui
est petit commerce est comme ça au mois
il pourrait continuer à vivre et faire
des hanches
ce kit avec l'image bonus à présent ça
fait un peu et aux cadeaux bonux
d'ailleurs c'était la même époque un
1965 on d'état al entre deux tours de la
présidentielle et le général de gaulle
donne une interview oui c'est la
première présidentielle à se dérouler au
suffrage universel direct à l'issue du
premier tour de gaule et mise en
ballotage face à une gauche unie autour
de la candidature de françois mitterrand
alors le général se positionne plus que
jamais comme le rassembleur au dessus
des partis il sera finalement réélu au
second tour avec un peu près de 55% des
suffrages
la france c'est tout à la fois c'est
tous les français
c'est pas la gauche la france c'est pas
la droite la france prétend de faire la
france avec une faction
c'est une erreur grave
et prétendre représenter la france
au nom d'une fraction
cela c'est une erreur
nationale 1 par bonnart et c'est la fin
de france 2022 lors du soin merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivi merci h rennes
france 2022 l'heure du choix retrouver
sur notre site internet france 24 points
comme également sur les réseaux sociaux
rendez vous lundi prochain même heure
[Musique]